I think Americans obsess a lot over
celebrity but I think that the thing
about Britain you have to remember is a
small country it you know there's an
expression that they use saying that you
punch above your weight which means you
kind of play with the big boys when
you're not such a big boy so Britain you
know tries to be more of a kind of world
figure than it may be is and so it kind
of wants to do in America does but it
doesn't have as many celebrities it
doesn't have as many serious things to
fill its paper with papers with as
America does so it it has this weird
celebrity culture filled with not that
important celebrities actually a lot of
newspapers that it has to sell and a lot
of tabloids that are completely
Hollywood eyes I mean they're all about
kind of crap really and and so so you do
it's in the culture much more I mean
there is a kind of lack of seriousness
and discourse there because of all that
I think it's really brought down the
tone of a lot of the papers all this
celebrity stuff
I interviewed him right before the dark
knight was rapping I think he was in his
last couple of months of filming and he
was you know he first all he's really
good-looking a lot of movie actors
aren't good looking at all when you meet
them you know they're much smaller than
you would hope they were which is fine I
have nothing against short people but
that you know but you're disappointed
because they don't look the same as you
want them to look and he was like a big
strapping you know australian guy he
clearly was really bright really
creative very restless and you know but
charming and charming and intelligent
and clearly having a tough time with the
filming and one of the things we talked
about was insomnia because I suffer from
insomnia as well so we were sort of
trading tip so you know what kind of
drugs to take and what kind of you know
techniques we used and he it kind of
hauntingly said you know I've been
taking ambien and I took one last night
and it didn't work so I took another one
and then I only slept for an hour and he
said you know my mind is fizzing with
this role I cannot get my mind to shut
up and he didn't seem like he was you
know on anything he just seemed like he
was clearly somebody who was one of
those people who get so into his work
that he couldn't calm it down those
voices that were you know all excited
and fizzy and so I felt just so sad at
the way he died because clearly he was
talking about that and as clearly was a
mistake I think because he just couldn't
get any sleep and I know what that feels
like it's awful and so it was just
shocking because he seemed he was so
full of life and so lovely and we talked
about his daughter he was you know a
little baby daughter he just loved her
and it was just such a waste it was so
sad and again you know I just had would
have had no idea and he certainly wasn't
suicidal he was really full of life but
it was so poignant he was living in a
beautiful rented house in London and had
I think three or four bedrooms they took
me on a tour beautiful place and he
showed me every single bed had been it
was all mussie you know all the sheets
were everywhere he said because last
night I just
couldn't sleep so I went from bed to bed
hoping I could fall asleep somewhere
just so sad just so sad and you know you
wonder if someone had really kind of
taken him in hand and said you know
let's this movie's hurting your health
let's try to work on this if he could
have been helped who knows you know
creative people are you can't really you
don't really have answers do you um you
can't really know what makes them tick
but it was it was just it was a tragedy
real treasure